this school doesn't teach snorkeling 101
they train students to become
professional divers for the toughest
underwater jobs like constructing and
maintaining high sea oil platforms
repairing and building dams and bridges
for salvaging old shipwrecks
no underwater task is off-limits for
these divers Adam Allah shucks is one of
their top students today is a big day
for Adam he's been training seven months
for this moment the final exam that will
determine if he's got what it takes to
be a professional diver Adam is about to
go through a simulation that will put
all his skills to the test this is a
life and death scenario so like life
failure is not an option when you're in
this industry you only get one chance
when you're down there so you got to be
on top of your game you got to make sure
you know what you're doing everybody has
to do this before they graduate and Adam
last Chuck ABS absolutely has to go
through this today Adam will have to
rescue a fellow diver trapped underwater
with a faulty umbilical cord the hose
that supplies divers with oxygen
the trapped diver can rely on limited
backup air tank but rescue divers are
standing by just in case the surface
mark atom needs to be prepared for
dramatic situations like this one
they're part of the life of a
professional diver Adam jumps in and
makes his way toward the trap diver
absolutely is a timed event if he
doesn't get it done in time that divers
going to run out air and it's gonna be
bad business
two minutes have passed and Adam is
getting ready to swap the umbilical
oxygen supply
he will disconnect the other divers air
hose that diver will have no air except
for the air that the diver is carrying
on their back and he will actually
connect a new umbilical hose to be able
to get the diver from being unwrapped
and bring them to the surface safely
a three-minute mark Adam now replaces
the faulty air house poor visibility
makes this difficult
shackling in the new restaurant he
fumbles trying to hook up the valves but
finally he succeeds bold umbilical
screen cleaners service go ahead and
take up on the old and/or put that
straight out let's get on it
the ball beam goes well that's the old
one the new ones attached now we gotta
bring them both back together time is up
and both divers rush to sea level
wander over here understand
good job Nick right on time man 36
seconds hit him up and over